[ Smoke alarm beeping ]
Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
When you're trapped
in a real house fire,
three minutes to escape.
I'm dead.
[ Pop, whistle ]
Oh!
‐My God!
‐Damn!
‐Holy smokes!
Be a part of our
chocolate milk revolution.
Ohh!
We're looking to build
a restaurant empire.
‐What are the sales so far?
‐$40,000.
It is absurd!
If you're worth $4 million,
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I got to be worth
like $4 billion.
No, that's me, Kevin.
‐That's Mark.
‐Ouch.
There's a hungry window company
out there
that's gonna take
this flyer.
I don't think
that's ever gonna happen.
You are single‐cell amoeba.
Narrator:
And we check in on how
some "Shark Tank" companies
are helping during
the coronavirus pandemic.
We are modern‐day
Rosie the Riveters
in the battle
against COVID‐19.
Our brand was built
to help out our community,
and this is more true today
than ever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is what happens
in New York City every night!
Thank you to our heroes!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
are innovations
to make working
and learning easier.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
I want that.
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Anthony Franco, and I'm from
beautiful Denver, Colorado.
I'm the CEO and founder
of mcSquares,
and I'm seeking $300,000
for 10% of this ‐‐
our family of collaborative
dry‐erase products so ingenious,
we named it after Einstein's
legendary equation
E = MC squared.
Oh, it wasn't me?
[ Laughter ]
These are reusable
dry‐erase stickies.
They stick
without any adhesive,
so you can use them again
and again.
A six‐pack
of mcSquare Stickies
can replace
over 12,000 paper sticky notes.
[ Pop, whistle ]
Oh!
‐[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Damn!
‐Holy smokes!
‐Oh, my God!
‐Damn!
‐I'm sorry.
‐That is beautiful.
‐Don't do that again.
‐I need a restroom break.
[ Laughter ]
It's a total waste
of resources,
and, Mr. Wonderful, it's a waste
of your favorite ‐‐ money.
Let's do the math.
1,000 paper notes on average
costs 22 bucks.
Multiple that times 12,
and you get $264
for 12,000 paper sticky notes.
Now, for comparison,
a six‐pack of mcSquare Stickies
costs around 20 bucks.
264 minus 20, and you get
well over $200 in savings.
What's worse is, if you multiply
this math times 50 million,
you get 60 billion.
That's how many paper notes
are discarded every year.
That's roughly
250,000 trees' worth.
Now, that was some
pretty boring math, but wait.
There's more!
[ Laughter ]
‐If you act now...
‐There always is.
...I'll throw in
my four‐in‐one tablets.
Our dynamic dry‐erase tablets
allow you to layer your thoughts
during brainstorming sessions
and let your ideas
truly blossom.
And you can seamlessly line up
your calendar events,
like for me,
when I'm planning to write out
your big, fat
return‐on‐investment checks.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So, Sharks,
now that we don't need
all this paper for notes,
let's recycle it into confetti
and celebrate our deal.
How about I bring you
some samples?
Good enough
Rohan, this is a tablet
and our calendar.
Oh, wow!
‐Oh, wow!
‐It's a great sketch.
Wow.
Did you do that?
‐Yes, I did.
‐You're an artist?
‐I'm a wannabe artist.
‐Thank you, sir.
Except, Rohan,
doesn't look like you.
‐It's fantastic.
‐You don't look that good.
‐Well, honestly...
‐Aw, girl, please. Girl, please!
Your eyes look a little,
you know...
...the tablets allowed me
to cheat. They're templated.
So I actually put a picture
of you underneath...
You can overlay. Yeah.
...and I was able
to trace you underneath.
Tell us your story
a little bit,
'cause you got a lot
of creativity going on here.
How did you get here,
and what was this "Aha" moment?
I barely graduated high school.
[ Chuckles ]
I was a stereotypical teased‐
and‐picked‐on computer nerd.
I was kind of a wallflower.
Aw.
I didn't engage with
our teachers
and with fellow students.
Hard to believe,
looking at you right now.
That's changed.
It's forced.
I swear to you, it's forced.
‐I don't believe you.
‐[ Chuckles ]
So I started
a little consulting business,
and we had
this amazing meeting,
a lot of pompous executives
in the room.
Well, it was over, we were
patting ourselves on the back,
and a saleswoman
who had been in the meeting,
who had said nothing
in the room,
came up to me and said,
"Have you thought about..."
and then started laying out
all the stupid decisions
that we made
in a very nice way.
And I thought, "Well,
how come we couldn't get her
to speak up in the room?"
And so I took our whiteboard,
carved it up
into little squares,
handed it around the room.
It was like magic.
Everybody contributed.
In certain environments,
everybody's scared to speak up,
and the people
with the best ideas
are the ones that are
least likely to share them,
and that's the impetus of
the version 1 of the tablet.
O'Leary: You're slapping it onto
a magnetic surface, right?
Yes.
The surface
has to be metallic.
Yes.
So this is primarily
in the home.
That represents
the refrigerator, I guess?
Yes.
I think I planned for that.
[ Chuckles ]
So ‐‐
But where do I find that
in my office? What surface ‐‐
Yeah. Excellent.
This ‐‐ We've sold 30 of these
this year.
But offices today have
more and more glass in them
than anything else.
So, our product for that
is our stickies.
So the stickies ‐‐
like I said, they stick ‐‐
What does that stick ‐‐
what substrate
is that sticking to?
Anything smooth.
So if a suction cup will stick
to it, this will stick to it.
The dry‐erase boards
that are already in offices?
Yes, exactly. Exactly.
So, who is the audience
you're going after?
It's anybody looking for
paper sticky notes.
We've only been in market
with those for four months.
What are the sales
so far?
So, this year,
we've done $214,000.
Whoa!
We'll do $110,000
this month,
and we'll do a million dollars
this year.
‐Ooh!
‐Something is spiking here.
You've been around for a while.
‐Mm‐hmm.
Last year,
you sold 200K.
This month,
you expect to do $100,000?
Something's wrong there
with the math, right?
So something is exploding
in your sales
from going from $200,000
in an entire year ‐‐
nice, interesting numbers,
but not overly exciting...
Yeah.
...to basically
a $1.2 million run rate,
assuming you sustain that.
‐Yes, sir.
‐What suddenly changed?
So, the first version
of our product,
I contract‐manufactured.
So I sent it overseas,
called to make my next order,
and ‐‐ a big surprise ‐‐
I had manufacturing issues.
You've never heard that before
in the Tank.
‐No. First time. First time.
‐Ever. You're the first.
So, the manufacturing issue
was they lost the molds.
The molds?
The molds.
They lost the molds.
They stole the molds.
No one loses molds.
Greiner: Tell me, please,
that they remade the molds
and paid for it.
‐No.
‐No?
I had a decision to make ‐‐
I could have fought that,
but getting the feedback
on version 1, I thought
maybe we had an opportunity
to redesign a little bit
and be more in control
of our own destiny,
so I brought manufacturing
in‐house.
We redesigned
the entire product line
so we can manufacture it
in Denver.
What's the long‐term strategy
on cost?
Well, our margins on stickies
is 92%.
And can you scale that?
So, the factory that I built
can scale to 10 million,
and the plan ‐‐
‐$10 million?
$10 million
in retail revenue.
That's not a lot.
What I'm picking up from you,
listening to you,
is every question we ask,
you give a three‐part answer.
You're all over the board.
Are you organized?
No.
O'Leary: Ooh.
Who let you in here?
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Anthony's admission
may have tanked his chances
for a deal for his innovative
office‐supply company mcSquares.
What I'm picking up from you,
listening to you,
is every question we ask,
you give a three‐part answer.
You're all over the board.
Are you organized?
No.
Ooh.
Who let you in here?
Well, that's why
he's got stickies.
Greiner: But I love
that you're honest.
But I have organized people
around me.
Corcoran:
You're definitely honest.
That's a great answer.
It took me a while
to get comfortable with the fact
that I suck
at organization.
Good for you on that.
Thank you.
Now,
the unfortunate side is,
I have a company
called Writeyboard
that does not the same things...
‐Yeah.
...but they're
whiteboard‐driven,
and there's
some similar products.
So, for those reasons,
I have to say I'm out,
but congratulations.
Thank you, Mark.
Look at you.
You are not a wallflower
anymore.
[ Laughs ]
You're amazing.
I think you should be extremely
proud, standing here today.
It's a really cool concept,
but this isn't a product that
I really feel passionate about.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I would never,
in any capacity,
see you as an introvert
up there
or someone who lacks
a huge amount of confidence.
Your energy
is infectious.
I don't understand
the product fully.
Ugh!
I see the problem
you've delivered,
which is hundreds of millions
of sticky notes flying around,
but I don't know
if people will see that
as a major problem
for themselves.
So, unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
Ugh.
I want to pull you back in.
[ Chuckles ]
You're the kind of guy
that I'm in love with, okay?
[ Chuckles ]
Because you're the guy
that I identify with.
I was a dumb kid
out of 10 kids.
All my siblings got straight A's
without opening a book,
and I never got anything
beyond a D.
I was the kid in school
that the kids laughed at
when I was made
to read out loud.
I would've just jumped in
any hole I could possibly find.
Yeah. Totally identify
with that.
And I was the only kid
with no friends.
So I love people like you.
But I'm being reminded of
how much I love my sticky notes.
I think I'm gonna go
in that direction.
I think I'm
going to go out.
Thank you, Barbara.
So, I'm in this business
on both sides.
This office business
is a two‐tier distribution,
so that's not gonna work.
It's just not gonna work.
This business
is interesting.
What I hate about it
is the factory, okay?
I've sold $40,000 of those
this month online.
No, I get it,
but that $10 million,
Anthony, is nothing.
When you scale,
you'll get that
in a week worth of orders
if it works.
But if I'm gonna take
this journey with you,
10% is not enough at all,
given the risk.
Fair.
Here's my offer. It's
the only one I'm gonna make.
$300,000 for 25%.
I really appreciate
your thoughtfulness.
You're bringing up things that
go through my head every day,
and I appreciate
the connections that you have
for manufacturing
outside of the U. S.
and would love
to tap into that.
I mean, you got to scale, man.
You got to get big.
We're on the same page.
I totally agree with you.
Do you like his offer?
It's definitely more equity
than I wanted to give away.
So, what's the counter?
Would you be willing
to do 20%?
No.
I've been where you are already
multiple times, my friend.
Fair.
This is not going to be easy.
It's hell.
For me,
that's 25% or nothing.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
I'd love to have you
a part of the team, Kevin.
You have a deal.
[ Applause ]
‐Wow.
‐Congrats.
Thank you, my friend.
Thank you, sir.
Here.
Thank you.
‐Congrats, Anthony.
‐Love your jacket.
‐Wish you the best.
‐Thank you.
Oh, did I mention the jacket
is thrown in on the deal?
Give it to Mr. Wonderful.
Really?
[ Laughter ]
It's yours.
Let me try that on.
It should fit.
He's got four more.
[ Laughs ]
It does fit.
Thank you very much.
Oza: Look at that!
Now, that's
a Mr. Wonderful look.
Alright. Thank you, guys.
Thank you very much.
Nice.
Franco: Anybody that has Kevin
as a partner
is super, super lucky.
This was easily the hardest
thing I have ever done.
Easily.
And I'm super grateful
for being a part of this show.
It's any entrepreneur's dream.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a solution for one of
the biggest dangers in a home.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Eric Hartsfield.
And I'm Brett Russell.
Together, we are Rescue Ready,
from Norfolk, Virginia.
We are here seeking $75,000
for 15% of our company.
As firefighters, sadly,
we see the tragic fates
of families that don't have
a quick and safe way
to escape a fire
in their own home.
Sharks, we are here to tell you
it is not like you see on TV.
When you're trapped
in a real house fire,
there's scorching flames,
dark smoke, and toxic gases
that are very likely to block
your doors and hallways,
leaving windows
as the only pathway to safety
for you and your family.
We've seen firsthand how
the increased use of synthetics
in building materials
and products
means fires are burning hotter
and faster than ever before.
Three minutes to escape.
Think about that.
That is why
we created Rescue Ready.
Rescue Ready is an emergency
escape ladder system
that is fully integrated
into the frame of the window
and anchored to the structural
components of your home.
To use Rescue Ready,
simply raise the window...
remove the cover...
take out our ladder...
remove the strap...
and throw.
Within seconds, even a child
can begin evacuation.
Wow.
People need
a practical means of escape,
one that is already connected
exactly where you want it,
when you need it most.
Okay, Sharks.
Both: Who's ready
to be rescue ready?
You won't get burned
on this deal.
[ Laughter ]
Oza: Oh, nice!
Alright,
let's have some fun.
We want to do a demonstration.
I need two volunteers.
‐I'll volunteer.
‐Awesome. Come on up.
‐Do high heels work?
‐Oh, we can make them work.
Do you sleep in high heels?
‐No, no, no. [ Chuckles ]
We're gonna have you use
the ladder
that everybody's
familiar with.
It's the one that's sold
in the big‐box stores.
It's the one
the manufacturer tells you,
"Keep it in the closet
or keep it under the bed."
We're gonna have you use that
for the demonstration.
Alright, have a seat
right here.
Mr. Oza.
The goggles Eric's passing out,
they're very similar
to the way we train
in the fire department.
We've placed a cover
over the lens.
It simulates a smoky room
and enables us
to really practice
with limited visibility.
When y'all hear the alarm,
you're gonna sit up...
Mm‐hmm.
...you're gonna put
your goggles on
and you're gonna make your way
to the windows.
Mr. Oza,
you're gonna make your way
directly to
the Rescue Ready window.
Got it.
Okay?
Once you get that ladder out
and in your hands,
we're gonna stop you and tell
you to remove your goggles.
Ms. Corcoran,
just remember,
you've got to go under the bed
to get yours, okay?
But she's got a dress on.
You might want to do it ‐‐
‐Okay, let's switch, then.
‐You want to switch?
‐Let's switch. Alright, Mr. Oza.
‐Oh, great!
Oh, you sucked them right in
there, Barbara.
Oza:
I got suckered in here.
Now you have to go under
the bed and get the ladder.
Better.
Okay?
So, the manufacturer
recommends that.
We're gonna put it
right here.
Alright, go ahead and lay back.
Don't put your goggles on yet.
Alright,
let's get ready to go.
Something's not right, man.
Something's not right.
Fires never happen
the same day
that the dad goes
and buys the ladder...
You're right.
...gives it to the kid,
explains it,
and shows them
where they put it.
Alright,
so, what do we got to do?
I think it's safe to say
this is way too neat.
Alright, come on.
Let's mess it up a little bit.
Shoes.
Shoes?
What is this? Toys.
Toys.
I'm getting royally jacked.
A ball.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Blanket.
You are jacked.
So,
y'all ready to go?
‐Yeah.
‐I'm ready.
Game time.
[ Smoke alarm beeping ]
[ Grunts ]
Plus,
I'll mess my hair up.
[ Beeping continues ]
Russell:
High heels and all. Nice.
This is the bed. Box.
Alright,
make your way over here.
It's not that one.
Okay, fire, damn it!
Alright, so,
a couple things
that Mr. Oza's not having to
deal with right now, right?
There's no heat.
Alright, great job,
Ms. Corcoran.
There's no heat
right now.
You're ready to go.
Oh, cool.
You found some shoes.
Oh!
There's no heat.
All we're asking him to do
is get this simple contraption,
right, over to that window
and attached properly.
[Bleep] I'm dead.
He's dead.
I'm dead.
So, I think we demonstrated
really clearly...
Wow.
...how difficult
the existing ladders are
to use in
a real stressful environment.
They're just
really unrealistic.
Have you started
selling these yet?
So, we are
a licensing play.
Okay.
So no, we have not.
So, we're gearing this ‐‐
the most optimal situation
is for new construction.
Take the side of the window
manufacturer for a second.
So,
I'm the giant window guy.
You come to me with this patent
and you show it to me,
and I say to myself,
"Okay, that's gonna increase
my cost for that window by" ‐‐
By how much?
About what? 200 bucks?
100 bucks? How much?
$90.
$90 per window. Okay.
Spaced out over a 30‐year
mortgage ‐‐ 28 cents a month.
Oh, you're not just gonna do it
for one window?
One in every
second‐floor bedroom.
The problem with that is,
It's the builder.
it's the consumer and the person
living in the home
that worries about it
and cares about it.
The builder is just trying
to put up a home
at the cheapest amount
that he can
and sell the home
for the highest amount.
That's where I see
the challenge.
Oza: But couldn't you
upsell this?
So, when people are building a
house and picking out things...
Could be an option.
...they pick out
their carpet...
Yeah, it's an option.
...they pick out
their paint colors...
For you guys to make money
on this...
Yes, sir.
...you're looking for ‐‐
like, every time they use one,
what do you expect them
to pay you?
10 bucks?
What's the scenario?
Well, we'd go after
a very moderate 6% royalty.
6% royalty?
Yeah.
For them to put this and
change it into their tooling ‐‐
so, are you confident that,
for $90, they can do that?
Because they've got to change
a bunch of tooling
to put this in.
They do,
but it's gonna pay off,
because if they advertise
properly,
they're gonna have moms and dads
that want these windows.
And you haven't approached
any home builder
or window company and said,
"Hey, guys" ‐‐
Like, have you got any sort
of test feedback from that?
We have been scared to death,
being new to this,
about doing that,
until about three weeks ago...
You don't want to release it.
...because of the patents.
I mean, we're new to this.
Look, we're firefighters, right?
No, I respect that.
We're so new to this,
and it's our baby,
and we don't want anybody
to steal it
and we've been so hesitant.
That's smart of you.
You got to know going in,
this is a 5‐ to 10‐year haul.
Industries ‐‐ particularly
residential construction ‐‐
have been doing it
the same way for eons.
It's gonna be a long slog.
I'm just not the
residential‐construction guru
that some of these folks are,
so for those reasons, I'm out,
but congrats.
Thank you, Mark.
It's a great idea.
Yeah.
Thanks for the time.
What I see here is
a large fly in the ointment,
and the fly is, you got to pitch
to a window manufacturer
that they should change
their formula for success
with no upside to them.
They're excited about
their bottom line,
and this is a disruption
to their bottom line.
So, I would suggest you
have to take your wonderful box
and think of another place
to house it.
I would take
that same beautiful box that,
if it were lower
below the window
and screwed into the floor,
it would almost look like
a slim air conditioner
that wouldn't really
bother people.
It would accomplish for you
what you want,
which is to have it in its place
when it's needed,
but you wouldn't have to
partner with a window company,
'cause I don't think
that's ever gonna happen.
So, to the point of no upside
for the window company ‐‐
there'll be
a $90 to $100 increase
in the price
of the window itself,
and, plus,
if they market this right,
they're gonna sell
houses full of windows.
If they market it right,
if they change their catalogue,
if they change
their manufacturing,
if they upcharge...
Cuban:
It's gonna be tough.
What about Barbara's idea
of doing the floor?
I think what Barbara's
trying to say ‐‐
you always want to control
your own destiny.
I'm afraid I'm out.
I just don't think it will fly.
I wish you great success,
'cause this does save lives.
I get it. But it's a journey
I can't go with you on.
I'm out.
Okay.
Appreciate it.
Um...
Listen, everybody
that watches "Shark Tank" knows
I have a soft spot
for firemen.
Me too.
Everyday heroes.
And it kills me
to not give you an offer.
But I just don't feel
it's investable for me,
so I'm out.
You guys
are truly quality people.
Thank you.
But you're running uphill
with a backpack full of rocks
because you're having the guys
retool stuff
they've spent hundreds
of millions of dollars
building on lines
to get efficient as heck.
Well, thanks very much.
Just to touch on
a couple things you said ‐‐
It's a whole lot
to ask these companies
to change the way
they've done business for years.
The good thing
about that is,
there's hundreds
of window companies.
So, we don't land a deal
with 1 through 10?
No big deal.
There's a hungry window company
out there
that's gonna take
this flyer,
and they're gonna take
the flyer
because parents are gonna want
this in their house.
I agree.
I just wish
you'd come in
with one of those
hungry window companies.
So, unfortunately,
I'm out.
♪♪
Thank y'all very much
for your time.
‐Good luck, guys.
You'll figure it out.
‐Good luck, gentlemen.
Boy, talk about guys
getting deflated.
Yeah, definitely. Oof.
Ohh!
That path is
a long path.
It kills you.
Oh, that's brutal.
Russell:
Maybe I'm just naive.
I don't think
it's that big of an ask
to have window companies
out there at least consider it.
So, America,
you need this product.
We want to get it to
any American that wants it.
And there's a window company
out there
that's gonna step up
and help us do that.
Gonna do the right thing.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a grown‐up
version of a childhood favorite.
♪♪
What up, Sharks?
I'm Manny.
I'm Josh.
And we are Slate Chocolate Milk.
We're seeking $400,000
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
Sharks, you can be the happiest
version of yourselves
if you embrace who you are
and what you enjoy.
Lori, you can sing in traffic
if it makes you smile.
Mark, you can wear that hat
if you feel like it's just you.
[ Laughter ]
‐And, Kev, my guy...
‐Yeah!
...my guy, you can do
that workout,
'cause if it's exercise
to you...
Nice body.
...who cares?
And, Sharks...
Nice socks, Kev.
...that's why
we can chocolate milk.
[ Tab pops ]
Literally.
We are Slate,
the first lower‐sugar,
higher‐protein line
of lactose‐free chocolate milks
for adults.
We use a process
called ultra‐filtration,
which allows us
to filter out
the natural lactose sugars
from milk,
leaving us with a creamy,
better‐for‐you chocolate milk.
We pair that with a popular
latte canning process,
which makes these puppies
shelf‐stable,
able to be shipped
to your doorstep.
Sharks,
you can be a part
of our chocolate milk
revolution.
So, who wants to join
us modern milkmen
and give chocolate milk
a clean slate?
A clean slate?
[ Laughter ]
‐Let us try it.
‐Yeah, we got some.
‐Mark and I can drink this?
‐Yes. Lactose‐free.
'Cause this will be
a very short pitch if we can't.
And just so you know,
before we hand these out ‐‐
we have one can.
It's just a prototype,
though.
The can is just
a prototype.
‐That means presales, right?
‐It does.
$4 million valuation, huh?
On no revenue.
Kevin's gonna love ‐‐
Please. Allow me
to get the numbers.
‐And he's still smiling.
‐[ Laughs ]
So, what do you
want to start with? Dark?
‐We go dark first?
‐So, dark first.
‐Okay, dark first.
‐Dark first.
Lubin:
So, this dark chocolate ‐‐
we are targeting
the dairy‐alternative drink ‐‐
Ohh!
I do not like that at all.
Mark, do you drink
dark chocolate?
Do you eat
I eat dark chocolate.
You do?
Yeah. It's just...
‐I mean, I didn't love it.
‐Okay.
But when Mark threw up on it,
I liked it more,
so, like,
it's come the other way.
I like the classic
better than the dark, actually.
That's fair. So, the classic
should remind you
of that chocolate milk
that you drank growing up.
There's a distinct dryness after
you swallow it, on my tongue.
There's a little funky‐chicken
thing going on there.
'Cause I know what
chocolate milk tastes like.
It's one
of my greatest weaknesses,
and I would love to get away
from the calories.
Exactly.
I'm hoping
you're telling me
this is a big
alternative‐calorie option.
Absolutely.
Yes.
So,
we have 75% less sugar
than chocolate milks
currently on the market.
You could have three of
our cans, and that would equate
to the amount of sugar
and more or less calories.
So, we have 130 calories
in each one of our cans.
We have nine grams
of sugar.
Why is it so big?
So, the protein, baby.
Half of consumers
right now
are decreasing
the amount of sugar,
which is why we're playing
on that trend,
and increasing
the amount of protein.
What do you make it for now?
So, right now,
we make it for 85 cents.
Selling it to a distributor
at what price?
$1.77. 52%.
But they haven't
sold yet.
So, you'll be out at $3.99
at retail?
$2.99.
Corcoran:
You said it's a prototype,
so I would assume you haven't
produced the product yet.
Yes, so, we've done
a pilot run.
But yet,
you have a big price on it.
So, the valuation.
‐Yeah, let's get to that.
‐Let's talk about it.
We're going straight
to valuation.
O'Leary:
No, no, but I like it.
Either I eviscerate you now
or you defend it now.
We're gonna own it.
‐It is absurd!
‐So, what were you thinking?
So, you have two ridiculously
good‐looking founders,
which is a huge part
of the valuation.
Modest, too.
Only to Barbara.
So, our third partner was
a food broker for 40 years,
and he grew the largest
Greek yogurt company
from $140,000 in sales
to over $150 million
in the Northeast alone.
That is one of the reasons
it's worth $4 million?
He's invested in
three other businesses
that are all doing
over $20 million in sales...
‐So?
‐Wait.
...and he is a partner, and he
is basically our VP of sales.
So you don't need a Shark.
Greiner:
Wait, but you're saying,
"'Cause this guy was successful
with other businesses,
we're worth
this valuation"?
Yeah, it's a non‐sequitur.
Doesn't make sense.
So, the reason why
we talk that way
is because
of the relationships.
You know as good as anybody
in the food world,
it's all about
your relationships.
The way
that we're getting it ‐‐
we've gotten in front
of already four major retailers,
and we've been able to do that
because of him.
But it's all about the product
at the end of the day, right?
Absolutely.
You can have
a million connections,
but if people don't like
the product or the taste...
O'Leary: Wait a second.
The planet I come from,
it's all about the profits.
You don't have any.
You're asking us to pay
an enormous price...
Yep.
...valuated at $4 million
based on the fact
that you got a cool guy
that built another business
who's working with you.
That we don't know about.
If you're worth $4 million,
I wonder what I'm worth.
I've got
a lot of relationships.
Greiner: Yeah.
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I got to be worth
like $4 billion.
Oza: I would say.
No, that's me, Kevin.
That's Mark.
[ Laughter ]
It's ridiculous.
Ha‐pah!
We know we're at
the starting line.
I just don't want
that big foot to crush you.
I know it's coming,
and I know it's gonna happen.
It's gonna be ugly.
I'm doing everything
in my power
to help you
get us to that $4 million.
Yeah.
Yep.
In fact, you are now farther
away than when you came in here.
I think there's something here
that's, like, really wrong.
You haven't sold a thing,
but you're saying
that I should give you $400,000
on kind of
a wish and a prayer.
Do you realize
how that sounds weird?
Yeah.
I think that we probably
didn't frame the entire ‐‐
like, where we are
correctly.
I think that's probably
something we did incorrectly.
If you'd come in with sales and
other things and all of that ‐‐
You're just too early.
No, absolutely.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Have you guys raised money
already?
We have.
We raised about $200,000.
‐At what valuation?
Around a $400,000
valuation way back.
About a year ago.
So you sold half the company
for $200,000?
15%, and he bought in,
and he gives us 10 hours a week.
We're gonna pay
10 times more
than the "super sales dude,"
right?
I mean...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
...you're not even
chocolate milk cockroaches.
You are single‐cell amoeba.
You are nothing yet.
It doesn't taste good enough yet
to go to market.
You know
you got to work on it, okay?
I think that's fair.
I'm just telling you.
I appreciate it.
And I think
everybody agrees here.
So, I want
to be kind to you.
Definitely.
I'm working on a new,
nicer Mr. Wonderful.
Oh, good Lord!
And I'm having
a really hard time with you,
containing myself,
but I'm smiling.
I'm out.
Lubin:
Thanks for your time.
And that's fair.
Thank you, Kevin.
And just so you guys know,
we've done over 100 iterations.
But what you didn't provide
for us
is any proof that you surveyed
10,000 people.
But if you had said, "We've done
this many taste tests.
We've analyzed it.
We've perfected it.
We find that people
will pay the price"...
Right.
You basically went from
a business‐planning concept
to "Give us your money,"
and that's really rough
to ask any investor to do.
I think that's fair.
Yeah. We appreciate that.
So, because of those reasons,
I'm out.
Alright. Thank you.
Guys,
you saw my reaction.
For a protein shake,
okay,
you're willing to accept
that it's not the same.
Mm‐hmm.
I just don't think it's, like,
"Oh, wow, this is amazing,
and I just
have to have it."
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Alright.
Thank you, Mark.
Okay, Rohan, beverage guy.
Ro.
Okay, guys,
I like you guys' energy.
I like your thinking
of where you're going ‐‐
your protein's high,
your sugar's low.
Yeah. Yeah.
But when I go with my gut
on this,
and that's all we have to go
with when you have zero sales...
Yeah.
...my gut on the product is
it's just not there.
Okay.
Unfortunately, I'm out.
Appreciate it.
‐Go out and crush it.
‐Good luck.
‐Prove us all wrong.
‐Thank you for the time.
Really appreciate it.
‐Congrats, guys. Good luck.
♪♪
[ Sighs ] Man.
Belinsky:
It was really just, diving into
the valuation super early
didn't allow us to tell our
story, talk about our product,
talk about all the relationships
that we have.
It was a great
learning experience,
'cause if we had to do it again,
we'd do it differently.
Yeah,
and the Sharks were hungry.
Let me tell you.
They're just hungry.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a modern innovation
for ordering in.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is ‐‐
One second.
[ Grunts ]
Much better.
Beautiful Sharks,
my name is Jeff Appelbaum.
I'm from
Los Angeles, California.
I am here seeking ‐‐
deep breaths...
[ Inhales deeply ]
...$500,000...
‐Whoo!
‐Whoa!
...for 5% of my company.
‐Whoo!
‐Wow.
Today, I am here
to present Salted,
the largest delivery‐first
restaurant group in the country.
We create better‐for‐you
restaurant brands
built for today's
health‐conscious generation
without ever building
an actual four‐wall restaurant.
We focus on delivery
and have already partnered
with every major delivery
platform in the market today.
So, who's in the mood for
some guilt‐free pizza tonight?
With our flagship brand,
Califlower Pizza,
we make the world's best
gluten‐free
cauliflower‐crust pizza.
Mmm.
It's low‐carb
and only 100 calories a slice.
Cuban: No way.
Greiner: Wow!
Ooh, Mama, that looks good!
[ Laughs ]
But it doesn't end there,
my dear Shark friends.
Who's in the mood
for some Chinese tonight?
ginger bird is a vegan‐friendly,
soy‐free twist
that your whole family
is gonna absolutely love.
Want to spice it up?
moonbowls is a healthy
Korean‐inspired bowls concept.
When I eat this,
it is literally like a party
is happening in my mouth.
But perhaps
you want some greens
but you don't got
that green money.
Our brand,
the $5 Salad Company...
Corcoran: Wow.
...has delicious salads
for as low as...
$5.
...yeah, I think we're gonna
sell this one for 5 bucks.
By focusing on delivery,
we can operate not just one,
but a portfolio
of better‐for‐you brands
out of each one
of our kitchens,
sharing resources, ingredients,
labor, even shared rent.
Sharky Sharks, tell me,
[piece o']
who wants a pizza
this business...
[ Chuckles ]
...and to join Salted
in changing the way people eat
forever?
‐Wow.
‐Lovely.
Please eat.
I have some samples for you.
Front and center,
you have our famous gluten‐free
cauliflower‐crust pizza.
It's crispy like
a New York‐style cheese pizza.
It's gluten‐free.
This pizza is fabulous.
Pizza's solid.
Cuban:
I want another piece.
So, what am I eating here?
Is this the party in my mouth?
That is the party
in your mouth, Rohan.
I hope you brought
your party hat.
I did.
That's our avocado bulgogi.
That's Impossible meat.
We marinate it
in a garlic‐ginger‐soy sauce.
You have avocado, you have
some seaweed, some kimchi.
So some Korean‐inspired flavors
that make this brand ‐‐
This one looks like
a sweet‐and‐sour something...?
Orange chicken 2.0.
So, that goes
with ginger bird.
You think about
your orange sesame chicken
that you get
from a lot of places.
This, instead
of deep‐frying it,
we coat it with a cauliflower
dredge and then we bake it.
So we call it "oven‐fried."
That's great.
It's like
a sophisticated version.
It's fabulous.
Music to my ears, Barbara.
So, you are
an entirely online play?
There's no restaurant door
I can walk into
and have a seat, right?
We are optimized
for delivery,
and there's some pickup,
but there's no dine‐in.
So, I know a lot of
you guys are familiar with
the restaurant industry,
and we know the notoriously thin
profit margins.
A lot of those are sucked up
by the front‐of‐house.
There's a lot going on here,
buddy. It's very impressive.
Can you take me
to the beginning?
How did you get here with
five different meal concepts?
Yeah. Yeah.
I am obsessed with food,
and I am obsessed
with building things.
I actually started the company
five years ago.
Wow.
I'm on my third life
with Salted.
One of my favorite investors
told me recently
that I'm a cockroach
because I've survived.
Oh, I love cockroaches.
Was it Kevin?
So, version 1 of Salted,
it was an online cooking school,
a pure digital play.
Great business,
great economics,
wasn't scaling at the rate
that I wanted to.
Version 2 ‐‐ spent a lot of time
about 2 1/2 years ago
looking at the cooking‐kit
space, meal‐kit space,
the fundamental problems
of these businesses.
The fact is,
about 50% of those customers
are canceling
after their 30‐day trial,
and they're spending $200
to acquire those customers.
That's sort of like
the Plated problem.
The Plated problem, but they got
out just in time, didn't they?
Yes, they did. Thank you.
That was my deal.
Kevin, were you in that?
Yes, I was.
Highest return or size of exit
in "Shark Tank" history.
And of course it would be
Mr. Wonderful, as it should be.
[ Chuckles ]
As it should be.
Okay, here we are at Salted.
How's it going?
It's going very well.
Tell us about it.
How well?
I would love to.
So, we did 250K this month.
We're on a $3 million
run rate.
Wow.
We have five locations
open today,
and next year ‐‐
What cities?
We're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco, and Chicago.
Oza: Can you take me
through the year?
About $1.1 million
this year.
And we're increasing 20%
month over month.
And what did you make
or lose on that?
Over the last year,
we've been net‐negative 750K.
So, what we have
right now ‐‐
we have this giant market
of online delivery,
and it's subsidized
by a lot of private companies
and newly public companies.
So today,
our customer‐acquisition cost
is effectively zero.
Corcoran:
How is that possible?
We partner with
all these delivery apps.
Because you're on
all the different applications.
Yes.
Are you on
every single one?
I'm sorry?
Are you on every single one?
I order a lot.
I use Postmates, Grubhub ‐‐
everything.
We have partnered with every
major delivery platform.
And you are the first that sells
healthy, low‐cal food?
That's correct.
So, Jeff, but how do you
create awareness?
It's just you're just sitting
on Grubhub and Postmates or...
Basically.
are you doing stuff
to drive awareness?
So, we didn't do anything except
partner with a great company
that is bringing customers
to their experience.
Jeff, you know what's going on
with CloudKitchen?
I do.
For the viewer at home,
a CloudKitchen is a kitchen
where multiple delivery‐only
restaurants get to share it.
So you know that that's
basically a virtual opportunity
to do the same thing
you're doing?
There are folks that are
building the infrastructure,
and we can plug into
that infrastructure.
We're building the brands.
So you're saying you would use
CloudKitchen, potentially,
as a way to reduce
your capital costs.
Correct.
Okay.
How much have you raised
through outside investments
in those five years
you've been in business?
$5 million.
$5 million?
Yeah.
And how much have
those investors earned?
They're all still
on the cap table.
So they have not yet made
any money?
So, how much do you own?
Wait. I'm not done.
Okay, I'm sorry, Barbara.
Go ahead.
It's alright. It's alright.
So, for that reason alone,
I'm definitely out.
I have three questions.
One of the beautiful things
about the restaurant industry ‐‐
it's a many‐winner market.
I have three questions.
If you're selling pizza,
yeah, you might be
a competitor.
Hello.
If you're selling
Asian‐inspired bowls,
you might be a competitor.
But we are literally better
positioned than anyone else
to take advantage
of this giant sea change
that's happening right now
in food delivery.
I'm here because
we're looking to build
a virtual restaurant empire
that makes a massive impact
on people's lives.
So, Jeff, I'm kind of
conflicted here,
because I don't know
if you have a unique idea
from the CloudKitchen, 'cause
everyone's gonna be doing that.
So it boils down to,
as Kevin said, creating a brand.
But that's not the part
that throws me.
I really like you.
Thank you, Rohan.
And you also
make me nervous.
I'll be honest.
Like, there's something
energetic about you,
and then there's something
scary about you.
And I don't know which side
of the coin I want to go on.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Rohan is interested in Jeff's
modern food‐delivery concept,
Salted,
but he is conflicted
about the entrepreneur.
Oza:
I really like you.
Thank you, Rohan.
And you also
make me nervous.
I'll be honest.
Like, there's something
energetic about you,
and then there's something
scary about you.
And I don't know which side
of the coin I want to go on.
I speak fast,
so I get that, but...
Yeah.
...you speak
a little too fast, bud.
Okay.
So I don't know if I fully got
the answers to the questions,
and given that
I have concerns potentially,
if we worked together,
whether you would be listening
to feedback or not,
I'm gonna flip to the scary side
and say I'm out.
Jeff, customer acquisition
is the whole business,
at the end of the day,
and I love your claim
that you don't pay for it,
but all your competitors do.
You tell me
you're gonna take seven brands
and think that you can
support them individually.
Yeah.
It's seven times
the headache.
If I may ‐‐
Wait, wait, wait.
In the end,
it's the sharp marketer
that can acquire customers
at the lowest price.
Maybe it'll be you,
but your business is not worth
10 million bucks right now.
So, to talk through
the valuation a little bit ‐‐
Look,
you're an intriguing guy.
You are in
a very competitive market.
So, listen, Jeff,
I'm out.
But you still have
Daddy Warbucks over here.
So, Jeff,
the challenge is ‐‐
And Lori, no?
O'Leary:
You're not out, are you?
This isn't really
a food business.
I wasn't out.
I mean, it is on its surface,
but fundamentally,
it's an SEO‐on‐delivery‐apps
business.
So when CloudKitchen opens up
in every city,
how are you gonna
set yourself apart
when there's
a thousand delivery options?
We are building
great brands.
That's not the answer
I'm looking for.
I still think it's gonna take
unique SEO skill sets.
Absolutely ‐‐
so, once we get
this initial exposure
on these different apps,
we're able to put fuel
on the fire, right?
And how do you put fuel
on the fire?
It's intelligent marketing.
It's SEO, it's SEM.
Okay, so when you talk
about SEO, SEM...
Yeah. Yeah.
...where?
Well, we're targeting
specific customers
in the cities
where we're live, right?
People who are ‐‐
Within the apps?
When we do start
spending cash ‐‐
When you do? Okay.
Yeah.
We're not on the same page,
Jeff.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
And then there was Lori.
You know,
I have to say,
I'm the consumer
of this kind of food.
You finished it all,
Lori.
Because I eat ‐‐ Yeah.
I've been sitting here,
and I was the last one in,
but as you were speaking,
your eyes kept going to Rohan
or to anyone else.
I was the last one in
for you.
I don't know
if that made you nervous.
It's the dress
you're wearing, Lori.
But I think
it's really important
when I partner
with someone
that I feel that that partner
really wants me,
so I would have been in,
but in this situation,
I was not feeling that from you.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Ouch.
Cuban: Good luck, Jeff.
I appreciate your time, guys.
And, uh...
have a great day.
Good luck.
Corcoran: Yeah, good luck.
It went from high energy
to sadness.
I just want to say
something.
Don't you feel sad?
That guy
didn't get a deal
'cause nobody wanted to
partner with him.
Absolutely.
He avoided my eyes.
Appelbaum:
Wasn't super over‐the‐moon
with Lori's comments,
but I'm gonna be talking
to my mom about it later,
and we're gonna do
some deep therapy sessions,
so we'll see what comes of it.
♪♪